my name is Michael Plum I work for iller
where I'm responsible for a project on
intensification of Livestock systems
where feed is a is a key issue feed a
key issue in terms of determining life
productivity the overall economics of of
a livestock system but also how much
natural resources are we really using uh
how much are we affecting the
environment in terms of greenhouse gases
so feed is really at the inter phase of
say positive or negative effect
of livestock so to me the the the kind
of concluding sessions we had today was
very interesting because obviously a lot
of work has been conducted in the past
on feed Resources with an overall very
mixed uh
success and obviously looking at all
those very well sought new approaches in
terms of Innovation System in terms of
value
chains uh which were applied in the in
the ifat uh F adoption project in three
sides
Syria uh Vietnam and
Ethiopia had the potential to really
come up with new messages and and trying
to new insights trying to understand uh
where can we do better in the in future
than than in the past what were key
errors we committed in the past how can
we remed and and so on and a lot of the
the concluding session really was trying
to to find those kind of of key messages
in terms of what we can do better in in
the future uh what kind of Concepts were
developed and and proven by those
projects for example look at feed
resources in a wider context look at
feed resources in terms of systems look
at feed resources in terms of how they
help to connect people to markets how
they can improve value chain and I guess
that key message came was was really
realized and and accepted by by all the
very diverse people in the in the
different groups uh I was I was talking
to which is certainly uh a very
promising uh kind of of outcome of of
that uh project because it used to be
different in the past people were much
more technical much more focused on very
limited entry points so that's certainly
a a very good outcome of the the project
the workshop today couple of key issues
where people felt uh we need to do more
was trying to to understand those kind
of of feed gaps feed demand better
better in a way are we looking at
current kind of production aims yeah are
we only satisfying looking more at the
kind of subsistence idea of of lar
production or are we really committed to
something we call L Revolution that we
know
demand for meat and milk will increase
tremendously particularly in developing
countries which gives tremendous
opportunities for small holders to
produce for those kind of markets
however to be successful in producing
those markets they need to produce more
they need to produce more from fewer
animals they need to be competitive and
a couple of key issues around those
those challenges so uh came out very
clear from the from the workshop and and
from the the kind of concluding meeting
with had and one was really trying to
understand what is a feed Gap are we
defining feed gaps in terms of how much
more want Farmers to produce more in at
different scales at a household scale it
could be at at a country scale uh so
there were very very good ideas and
insights in terms of how we can improve
those kind of of feed resource demand
and predictions and of course mitigation
strategies coming from it in the
future um couple of Interest interesting
discussions in terms of uh are we
focusing too much on the positive side
of feeds feed supporting higher milk
higher meat production higher income and
are been necting so-called tradeoff
effects what do we need to produce the
feed we obviously need land increasingly
we need water water is an issue water
scarcity is an issue uh so there were
serious discussions about do we need to
do much more in terms of balancing
positive and negative
effects uh it's a very it's a very
difficult uh decision and to me it was
interesting to see that all the people
from or most of the people from all the
sites and from very different groups be
it research be it
extension uh very down the value chain
they seem to agree that we should focus
on
transition trying to move people out of
of poverty by increasing productivity by
increasing their production for the
markets and believing that once they can
move out of of Agriculture by education
by higher income or
whatsoever uh that we are essentially
looking at a new system in a couple of
years down down the line perhaps less
focus on very small Holdings like5
hectares one hectar which is the case in
Vietnam and Ethiopia just because people
have moved out of of Agriculture and L
of
production